one of the biggest challenges of
building a full stack web application is
managing complexity if you're building a
serious product you likely have multiple
front-end applications that communicate
with a back-end that share interfaces
with multiple team members that need to
collaborate efficiently today we're
going to look at NX from Narwhal a tool
that can dramatically simplify the way
you organize tests and share code
between multiple JavaScript applications
if you're new to the channel like and
subscribe and you can find the full
tutorial on NX dev the tool itself is
based on the best practices developed at
Google to scale thousands of
applications across thousands of
developers in a single mono repo but you
don't need to be operating at Google
scale to see the benefits of NX it can
be a very powerful tool for projects of
all sizes and not just angular but full
stack JavaScript in general so why do
you big companies like Google Microsoft
and Facebook like to manage their code
in mono repos or in other words use a
single git repository to manage multiple
apps and libraries the simple answer is
that this approach helps manage
complexity by applying best practices
organization-wide this delivers
consistency and predictability in your
code while also maximizing the ability
to share code between projects but you
can't just put all of your code in a
single repo and expect to reap the
benefits you need the right tool in
place to test build and deploy your apps
at scale and that's where NX comes in
over the next 10 minutes we'll look at
how complexity can grow very quickly in
a full stack project we'll build two
front-end applications one with angular
and one with react and then a shared
back-end with nest on top of that we'll
add multiple shared libraries that can
be used by all three of these apps let's
go ahead and create a new NX workspace
to see how it can help us manage a
project like this from the command-line
run npx create NX workspace followed by
your organization or product name this
will give us an empty workspace and
we'll be writing most of our code in the
apps and Lidz directories right out of
the gate NX is going to help you
separate your shared code from your
application code for example you might
have two front end applications one for
your customers and one for your
employees those apps would live in the
apps directory but they might share
common UI elements that would go in the
libs directory so this works really well
when you have a design system where you
share common UI elements across multiple
apps but you might also have a back-end
app that gets deployed to a node server
and if you're using typescript you'll
likely want to share interfaces between
your front-end and back-end code without
having to duplicate and regenerate that
code
those interfaces can also live in the
ellipse directory and be used reliably
throughout a large application let's go
ahead and imagine that we're building a
product for a travel company we have a
team of angular engineers who are
assigned to building the front end
customer facing app we can opt into
specific tooling for different
frameworks like angular react and SJS so
we'll go ahead and do that for angular
first our team of engineers want to use
modern test tools like Cypress ingest NX
gives you the option to just set those
things up automatically without any
configuration on your part now that our
workspace is configured for angular
adjust and Cypress we'll go ahead and
generate a new app that will create a
new angular app just like it would with
the angular CLI but tailored specific to
this workspace you can find the app in
the App Store e along with a folder for
end-to-end testing configured with
Cypress now up until this point we've
just been using the terminal to run
these commands but there's actually a
better way to do this
if you're using NX I highly recommend
that you install the angular console vs
code plugin the plugin allows you to
easily navigate all the commands that
you have at your disposal through NX you
don't need to memorize any commands or
search through the docs it's just all
right here in your IDE and this really
helps manage complexity because you
might have dozens of apps and libraries
in a single mono repo for example if we
only want to run the end-to-end tests in
our current booking app we can do that
by selecting the options we want and
then clicking a button and that will
give a cypress running and end tests for
this specific app and from the same
screen we can also run our component
unit tests which were set up with chests
and another cool feature of the console
is that it will save your commands in
memory so you can rerun them with these
same options by simply clicking a button
without having to think about it now
having this modern coin is really nice
but the most powerful benefits of NX
start to kick in as your app grows in
complexity at this point we just have a
single customer facing angular app but
let's imagine we have a separate team of
developers who are working on an
internal admin app for managing customer
bookings but this development team
prefers to use react now like I
mentioned earlier you can use NX with
any JavaScript project but it also
includes first-class support for react
we first need to opt into the react to
lien by running ng add Narwhal react and
if we go back to the console will now
have access to schematics specifically
for generating react applications and
components we'll go ahead and generate
our admin react app just using the built
in defaults and now we have a second
application in the apps directory along
with its own end to end test suite
now at this point we have a mono repo
with two individual applications in it
but one of the common misconceptions
that you may have heard is that putting
all of your code into a single mono repo
will slow down your testing and
deployment pipelines in a large project
you only want to rebuild and test the
portions of the app that have been
affected by change that might be an
individual application or it might be
multiple applications that have been
affected by a change to one of their
shared dependencies an ex can detect
where code changes will impact the mono
repo allowing you to efficiently work
with change in isolation at any scale if
we look at the git master branch you can
see we have a clean working directory
with no changes and if we go to the
angular console under dependency diagram
we can see both of our apps here which
are currently grayed out because there
are no changes but if we go and make a
change to our react app it will be
automatically highlighted in red and
because NX knows which apps are affected
by change in the current branch we can
test and build those in isolation and
this is what Narwhal means when they
talk about developing like Google
because a company like Google might have
thousands of apps under a single mono
repo and the only way to operate them at
scale is to understand what apps are
affected by change if you look at the
commands under the angular console
you'll see a bunch of them that are
prefixed by affected these commands
allow teams to work simultaneously on
several apps or libraries and be able to
build and test them in isolation without
having to worry about everything else
that's going on in the mono repo this is
especially important when you start
talking about code that might affect
multiple apps we can demonstrate that by
generating a library with NX that will
be used by both the angular and react
apps we'll go ahead and call this our
utilities library and because I used the
default schematic it's just going to
generate a vanilla typescript project
but you can generate frameworks specific
libraries as well now another feature I
want to point out before we go any
further is that you have the option to
add tags to your libraries this part is
completely optional but tags allow you
to control which types of apps can take
this library as a dependency for example
you might have a front-end shared
library that touches the Dom that you
wouldn't want to be used by a node
project so if a back-end developer tries
to use this library as a dependency they
will get a linting error that will tell
them it's a bad idea now if you've ever
created a shareable library you know
that there's a lot of steps involved you
need to set up your typescript config
your build scripts and all of your
testing utilities but as you're about to
see an X makes this entire process
completely trivial
at this point we'll go into the source
code for our utilities library and I'll
export a variable called unicorn rocket
that contains some emoji characters
because our design team said we need to
show these characters on every single
home page of every app throughout the
entire company now the awesome thing
about NX is that it makes code sharing
dead simple at the beginning of this
video we set up this workspace with an
organization name and we can now import
all of our shared code from that
namespace starting with the @ symbol all
the configuration is done for us so all
we need to do is import the code that we
want to use we'll start by doing that in
our angular app and then we'll switch
over to react and do the same thing
there so now we have two front-end
JavaScript apps sharing a common set of
utilities now the really amazing thing
is that NX will keep track of all the
apps that depend on the shared library
let's just imagine that our design team
comes to us and says that we need to add
an additional emoji to this string if we
make that change on a clean git branch
and then go back to the dependency
diagram we can see exactly which apps
are affected by the change so even
though we didn't actually change
anything on the main front-end
applications they'll still be
highlighted in red because they depend
on that utilities library which did
change and it's also worth pointing out
that there's an additional command
provided by NX that will help you
visualize the entire dependency graph
with the affected libraries being
outlined in red now at this point we've
only been talking about front-end code
but NX can also handle server-side node
projects with first-class support for
nest and Express and this demo we'll use
nest and the first thing we'll do is opt
into the schematics and then we'll go
into the angular console and find the
command to generate a new nest
application will give the backend a name
of API and its responsibility is to
fetch items from the database related to
customer bookings this adds a another
app to the apps directly but this time
without and end testing because it's a
back-end project now one of the most
common things to share between your
front-end and back-end code are your
typescript interfaces a nest will want
to read and write data in a back-end
database and make sure that that data
has a specific shape with a typescript
interface but will also very likely want
intellisense when we read that data and
use it in our front-end applications
what I'm doing now is creating another
NX library and then I'm going to add a
typescript interface to it called
reservation by putting this code in a
shared library we can now use it in any
one of our front-end or back-end apps
and on top of that we can leverage the
dependency graph to figure out exactly
which apps depend on this data type
so if this interface ever changes then
you know exactly which apps to test to
build and ultimately deploy to your
production server so there's a lot of
obvious benefits to a tool like NX
things like modern testing tools like
Cypress ingest a dependency graph that
will help you scale a mono repo to an
infinitely large team as well as task
runners and code generators to keep your
project organized and the end result is
a set of tools that will help you
develop like Google giving your
organization a predictable way to
collaborate and automate complex web
applications at scale I'm gonna go ahead
and wrap things up there if this video
helped you please like and subscribe and
make sure to check out the full tutorial
on NX dev thanks for watching and I will
talk to you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]